all right
todd hey how are you doing welcome back
well thank you for having me back
so it's been i don't know how many
months four or five months i think it's
at least so fast
i'm coming up on a year here you've been
well the last time we spoke you were you
were on your i was giving you a little
extra money to go to san diego
and i did appreciate it and i was but
well we didn't part of the reason i came
here
to la was to uh i had a bunch of hits
i got my wife had me arrested cost me
five grand my truck got stolen it was
just
my other truck broke down and just like
i kept getting hit after hit after hit
and i came here and i said i'm not
leaving here i came here for a weekend
i do my little hustle thing and you know
and i said i'm not leaving here until i
come up
and get back in the in the red i do
construction
and i can make as much money as i want
in construction i'm very
very good and i was part owner of a
contracting company
and um but when i'm using my drug of
choice
crack um and that's all i do
um i don't do that because i'm not
accountable
you know i might not show up on a job
one day and this and that and it burn
bridges
so i do a hustle and
um and i do rather well at that too
i do rather well at anything i do so you
just saw an extremist
you just showed me some photos of your
so most people that live on skid row
have little
tents oh yeah yeah crappy little tents
that are well
i've always wanted to build one when i
got here it was that was one of the
things that caught me
i mean these people are just san diego
you got from san diego
you can't just pop up a tent and just
leave it you got to take it down every
morning
yeah i come down here and these guys are
you know wow but you just showed me your
tent
yeah where you used some of your
construction know-how exactly i had a
front door
you had a door yeah had a barbecue grill
inside you had a barbecue with a hood
exhaust i had a full-on shower you know
with a tank
do you have running water oh well i had
a tank with a pump and it heats the
water
so it that that worked out great you
know microwave ac
refrigerator you had air conditioning oh
yeah
and also uh two um full
well one small tv and one big folder so
that means you have lots of female
companionship
oh yeah you can't get them out of there
i'm not everybody that comes here
they just is just it become overwhelming
they just you mean
you know like i i think i said that
before they they
this whole place will just suck you dry
i mean everybody
is after something you mean i i try to
maintain
myself i'm the type of person i just i
got it from my mom
she's i just like helping people you
know i mean and the more i help people
the more they take the more they want
the more they
i've yeah i've learned that i become the
atm machine for everybody like i see
that and that just kills me
yeah anyway um
what was i going to say so the police
the police figured out what you're doing
well
one of my one of my hustles became here
people i built
three different places layers or
whatever you want to call them
and everybody raved and they all wanted
them and they all didn't want to leave
so that become overwhelm i'm not type of
person that won a bunch of people around
you know maybe a female companion this
and that they just wouldn't stop
knocking on the door they just don't
this is what i mean
and another thing i'm very hostile you
know i always have food and this and
that and they
you know i always feed everybody or
whatever i i try try to help people
you mean but um down here they they
will just suck you dry but anyways back
to my place
um the guy in the back of the building
when he don't own the sidewalk but i'm
in front of his
area he came talked to me and said oh
wow
what is you the guy that owns the
mansion and i'm like
yeah if you want to call it that so he's
i'm having a problem with my get i
addressed it reframed things and
and the part of the problem was i framed
a wall
i've had other places and people just
cut the tent and steal my tools
i've lost not thousands of dollars ten
thousands of dollars of stuff
i am not kidding
every day here i take some kind of hit
every day but i just kind of brush it
off
because i'm good at what i do and and
just move on and and
but it is taking a toll on me well not
just
the the the skid roll people have sucked
me dry
uh lapd did a hit on me pretty good
uh that little that area that i had is
probably between
honestly between seven and ten thousand
dollars worth of stuff
it was four thousand just for the lumber
that i put in there and it was kind of
but i like doing what i do but it looked
like a tent it looked like a tent
you had a tent exterior but inside was
yeah it had a real front door but i had
a
car uh drape draping it and then uh
drive by and think it was a tent
that was my my idea but
yeah but inside it was actually uh
it was a framed walls it was a layer it
was just it was
secure yeah yeah i mean someone couldn't
just cut if they
anybody get in anything but they would
take some effort i had cameras too and
you had a bed
oh yeah memory foam it was all nice
but uh the pictures i showed you it
wasn't even complete
i had this one there's some talented
people down here i just one lady had ah
drapery she put some art on it and stuff
and i was gonna never do the whole place
you mean
so but one of the major no-no's here in
one of my other hustles here is hooking
up power for people
on here on skid row and they have it
everywhere the problem is
with me i mean there's a guy down the
street he's off the street got girl
i keep my place very clean uh when lapd
came in they said you know
they're worried about the corona viruses
oh we're gonna worry about no
coronavirus here this place is spotless
you know i bleach i clean everything
y'all the whole
police department after they arrested me
and took me to jail for hooking into the
power
so uh they came the day before
and i wasn't there and they told they
misled my neighbor and said they were
maintenance guys they needed to get in
the one of the boxes
well my my layer was over the box so
that night i stood up all night and and
reframed and moved the door
back so the boxes were clear so the next
day they came back
and i said well these guys ain't made
this is the city and they pulled in with
cops
two big dump trucks i mean they had like
four or five crews here
and i'm like what the f and they said
well this thing's you know
we can't have it because it doesn't
collapse three feet that's the code you
gotta have three feet
and i said oh i'm looking down the
street and i'm looking all these places
all
off the street and you know why they
[ __ ] with me
well the manager or the uh
the supervisor and the foreman came over
one day and told me i had
to expose the box so i did and um
i was trying to accommodate him he goes
wow this man you live better than i do
so can i can i take a picture so we took
some pictures when he was taking a
picture of
was the shower the electrical stuff i
was using so we called the city and told
them i'm stealing their water and their
electricity
so i never heard anybody down here
almost been here a year now came for a
weekend i've almost been here a year
you came for a weekend came just for the
weekend honestly and you've been here a
year
yeah i had a 50 000 job going i have
my my i have a handicapped child with
with
me and the mother gear along with i have
a wife uh
for the last 10 years it's been hell
because she got in her addiction too
so she finally i finally picked up
i haven't talked to my twin brother i
haven't talked to the only person i talk
to is my
youngest son in long beach and um
so i finally started talking to people
just recently
and she came up i got her to come up
and uh when i left she had me arrested
she had me
just putting sugar in my tank beating
just anything she could do to destroy me
she would do it
and because she was very jealous and she
loved me very much that she
would do these things and um
so she came up i'm like well maybe
things are she wanted me to come home i
said once you come up here
i want to show her my place oh that
didn't go for very well
because now i got all these [ __ ] up
in here i was her first thinking
she was right you know what i mean so i
said there ain't nobody coming up in
here and i don't do all that
and so she started the same thing
she started window you better not have
no cameras on me and just to start
and when she would do this before my
stomach would turn
my back would start to go out i mean she
would physically affect me
that's when i knew he needed to get away
and for my my well-being because
she was destroying everything of mine
calling customers up telling them i'm
screwing them and this and that
you know clients you know that i'm doing
work for uh
so when i was up here this is my wife
i love her so much i've been known for
over 20 years
and um she started at first thing my
stomach started turning i said man this
it ain't changing it ain't changing it
it's not going to change
she's made so much drama i had to drag
her out of my place and tell her to
leave
because the street i'm on the reason i
like that street it's regulated
by certain people they keep it quiet
they keep
they don't want attention because they
do their thing
and they don't want none of that going
on and sure enough they heard everything
we didn't hear you we heard her and
because she gets she makes drama
i mean yeah so your new life that you
have here on the street
and skid row i mean are you happy
uh i wouldn't say i'm happy uh because
i've been going through a lot of
depression
uh i have a hard time getting up in the
morning you know because i just don't
want to get up
you know but once i get moving but so
i'm not going to say i'm happy i got
comfortable here because of my addiction
it's easy to get things
um the female thing just become way
overwhelming you know i mean
because of the layer it's just like i
mean you know
and the other you know i'm there you
don't see too many
honestly you don't see a whole lot of
white guys down here
no you don't i stand now like a sore
thumb
some of them are i'm a target and i've
been around a little bit especially from
doing my drug of choice
you know dealing with a bunch of
different people a lot of people think
i'm naive i let them believe i'm naive
you know what i mean i just if if they
do me dirty i won't i just will not deal
with them again
they have all learned that i will not
deal with you ever again if you if you
do me dirty
so and a lot of most everybody here is
so how are you supporting yourself now
huh how are you living what are you
living off of
well you have savings no i live
right here i live day to day but like i
said i do rather well what i do
i mean you know when i have a vehicle
the the police have to
took all they they brought the crane in
destroyed everything they're supposed to
pack your property up
like i said i had between seven seven
and ten thousand dollars worth of stuff
so they've destroyed your lair they
destroyed the layer
there's it is only concrete there now i
just got arrested the other day first
they took my truck last night you slept
where
oh i've slept on a uh it reduced me down
to a somebody gave me a little one or
two man tent
that's what i'm on oh in with it empty
i have no vehicle the vehicle they
weren't going to tow my truck
but somebody broke into them busted the
locks prior to that
i think i told you this story i was
drugged and mugged in long beach
well they took all my paperwork and then
they busted my ignition and and
everything else and
so they're they weren't going to tow my
truck they said well how do you get in
the truck i said oh you got to get the
wire and do this
you know no ignition no paperwork they
said no no no no we're impounding this
truck
they thought it was stolen i said all
you got to do is check long beach
records and they'll tell you my truck
was stolen who owns the car
so of course they weren't going to do
all that they towed the car so now i
have no car
no place to live no nothing i'm
literally on the sidewalk
they they i picked up i don't know if
you're familiar with the bin
when when they they take all your stuff
here they're supposed to itemize and bag
every item and they take it to the bin
and then you go down and pick it up so
i'm on the sidewalk with 16 bags of
stuff
which eight of the bags are somebody
else's because i was storing their stuff
there
so i have eight bags of stuff left and
none of it's
not even my clothes it's all just it's
another
they either made a reason to throw
things away i said what'd you do with my
brain
i cornered the guy i seen him the next
day who who was in charge of the uh
loading stuff and he said oh well the
barbecue pit
we couldn't get the five gallon because
hazmat won't let you do like gas tanks
and things like that
they couldn't get the tank off so they
threw the barbecue away 400
barbecue i said it's brand new every
barbecue has a little screw that holds
the tank in place and it wasn't even
tight
and you couldn't get the tank off so you
decide to throw it away or keep it
so and then it goes on and on a number
of lot a lot expensive stuff
tools are missing uh the water heater
the the
it goes on my ass technically you're a
homeless person yeah yeah yeah yeah
i never considered you know i told the
cops i saw your home i said well i
really didn't consider my homework
being homeless until now you know what i
mean well you didn't own the property
that you were
so i didn't own it but um i was squad
still the squatter i guess but so the
moral of this story is what
that cracks the hell of a drug oh yeah
well that's the main reason that's kept
me here that is the crap and all the
things have been
everything has been revolved around my
whole life has been about the crack but
since i've been here
i mean it's so i mean i can go to any
corner i don't even have to make it to
the corner
to find it you know what i mean uh and
getting clean is not
something that's in the cars is it well
this is
when i left san diego i was doing i was
doing construction you know
and also doing my hug coming here on the
weekend doing my hustle
and i was making a lot of money i was
doing
at least a quarter ounce of crack a day
that's unheard of
that's unheard of that's seven grams of
crack a day
myself from the time i got up hold on
how much seven grams a day a day of
crack myself
most people would do 40 or 60 i'm and
one i know i know my addiction i've
gotten clean a lot of times and i'm
about on the verge of going into the
program
and i'm down on the verge to go back to
san diego but i'm not going to go back
i'm not going to go back using i'm going
to go back clean that's what i want to
do
so um yeah
i'm not using a quarter ounce of crack
now
but i still use at least two two to
three hundred dollars a day
you ask how i survive i make that and
survive
what food get a day you mean
and i do live day by day you know i
don't plan oh tomorrow
you know i i know enough to where i can
i know i'm going to get money tomorrow
at least that's my thinking i mean and
um
so it's it's really a sick thing it
really is an instance
and i know it and this has been my
longest run and this has been the most
usage
per day that i've ever done you mean
this i function very well on it
what is what does crack do for you been
asking i've been doing it a long time
yeah what it does for me it blocks
everything out
i get up in the morning i take i i've
been going through a lot of depression
i get up i start thinking about my
family and this what i ask myself
every day what am i doing here why am i
here
and um it blocks everything out
it allows me to do what i do as a hustle
i can't do it straight sober and um
i don't sell myself just so you know
the other night right after this all
happened i was down and out now you kind
of describe what your hustle is to me
off camera so
we won't get into that yeah i don't want
to get in that that might be
incriminating but anyways i'm very good
at it though
oh do you need any tools i see you guys
anyway um so i'm i'm down and out
right i wasn't gonna this guy i had no
money and i couldn't get no crack
so this guy pulls up and he's he's what
hey hey
the mexican wants you and i'm like
what's me what do you want me for i
don't know him
so i walk up to the car and he says hey
i am looking for this you do crystal
i said no i don't [ __ ] around i said i
do cabbie they call the crack caviar
and uh he said oh oh okay so well um
i like guys i said oh good good for you
good for you
he goes um i'll get you some cappy and
and pay you
let me suck your dick i'm like i i ain't
going out like that i'm not getting
doing i
determined i walked away i'm would not
bring myself to that you know i mean
that's just not me but that was funny i
got proposed
so made a proposal to me all kinds of
ways to make money here huh there's all
kinds of things
there's all kinds of way to make money
here it's it's it's amazing but
i i'm a little unique i don't i don't
i don't do anything here to make money
so you think you think you're on your
way
to getting clean that's where i'm
heading yes i've been here almost a year
my son it's it's i haven't talked to
family i haven't talked to anybody and
um
it's just i keep asking what am i here i
know i'm here i'm stuck
you know i mean i'm stuck on i know if i
go back to san diego
i can't make the money to survive to do
what i'm doing there
uh you know i can do construction but
like i said when i full on working i'm a
workaholic
i don't i i'm extremist i i do i go
after everything all the way
so um when i go back
i have to start working full on again
and
i need to be clean to do that you mean
because normally when i'm doing
construction i'm running jobs
first thing they'll they'll hire me or
whatever and i
work has never been a problem for me
even even the san diego pc
what are you doing and you know how many
times i've heard this line
if i could do what you can do i'd be a
millionaire by now
i should have been a millionaire my
partner says todd
he used to buy me crack just to keep me
wanting to keep me working
i ran the whole company you know what i
mean yeah i just said um
i've heard it over and over well lapd
has said man i'd be a millionaire right
now if i knew what you could do you know
what i mean
but the crack gets out of control
doesn't it well
i'm just oh it definitely gets out of
trouble i'm not gonna deny that
i'm very functional on it today i do so
much it don't even phase me
but when i'm not doing it um
the depression and then i just um
i just i'll go through uh heavy heavy
mood swings
it's not like the heroin addicts i don't
get sick physically sick and this and
that but
i haven't done it over
two years i've done it every day there
hasn't been a day i haven't done it
soon i go into panic as soon as i know
that i'm not gonna
even though i don't affect me you mean i
did a hit before coming here i'm fine
you know i mean most some people just
get they just i mean
i've seen people they just can't handle
it you mean they're like that's an
interesting drug isn't it
huh crack's an interesting drug it's
right up there with him
because you can be very functional on it
it seems no no
most people don't function very well in
it yeah i mean it's not like heroin
where you're nodding out and this and
that but
uh you get a fourier when you do crack
it doesn't last very long
that's why you the the worst thing about
crack is the one thing i didn't like it
when i first tried it because i used
just some
snort powder is you wanted
you want more immediately you want more
and more and more and more and more
there's not enough crack
in the world you just keep wanting more
and more and more and that's why people
fiend
on it so much uh and they do stupid
stuff you know i mean
and they and they rob and steal people
from people
but um that's what i don't do i don't i
don't rob from
people it's a very different drug than
crystal meth or oh yeah
yeah crystal myth i i i've been around
crystal meth is a whole another whole
another ball game yeah i mean
the thing with that is the fourier of
being up for so many days that's where
you start losing it on that stuff
and uh then people i just don't man they
have no sense of time
they're just they're you mean
so i i i don't i've tried crystal meth i
don't care for
it it just doesn't do nothing for me uh
i thought maybe i didn't smoke enough of
it one day i sat down and continued just
smoking a [ __ ]
because i know a lot of people convert
from crack and then they start doing
crystal meth my twin brother's one of
them uh
i won't mention his name
[Laughter]
he's not doing real well either when i
was at the police department they pulled
out a file about that thick
when he's we're twins and we've used
each other's names so when we get
arrested both our records come up
they think we're the one person i told
them it's my twin brother they didn't
believe me
but he's got a number of warrants out
right now
he's i haven't talked to him since i've
been here and he's
he's on the run and he's he does rather
well too he's very talented
i have an older brother and a younger
brother very talented
um he we do you know four brothers in
the family
i have an older brother and a twin
brother two and i'm the youngest
yeah addiction is it two of those three
all three
all three yeah at one time we're all in
prison at the same time
and what about your parents did they use
drugs no
no my dad was actually both my parents
were into sales my dad was
german he moved around a lot he wasn't
much in our life but
he partied a little bit but he
he did do drugs but very little and he
maintained he never really let it get
get a hold of me just snort a coke and
maybe smoke a little weed or something
about things like that
my mom never did drugs um
there was never there were no no really
no problems in the childhood anything
like that it's just
when i grew up in the 80s
everybody did coke everybody there
wasn't one person i knew that didn't do
coke
it was so abundant i mean that's when it
was just it was really hitting hard
you know in the 90s they started to
realize oh we got a problem here you
mean
but uh and back then the coke was coke
today i only know what the hell it is
that's the scary thing down here i
didn't want to touch base
you don't know what you're getting down
here i mean because they sell fentanyl
they sell heroin they say
and they putting a little bit of [ __ ]
into everything uh that's very scary
i mean uh one day i grabbed
somebody you know because fentanyl is
white i threw some stuff that was laying
there they left it
in my pipe and i immediately burned it
and smelt it i i didn't luckily i didn't
hit it it was fentanyl
you know i mean and a number of people
you could have died from that right
yes a lot of people here the main thing
that taking people out here is the
fentanyl
you know i hear it i hear it all the
time at least
at least twice a week i hear how
somebody and i uh well
what was it fentanyl sure enough you
know if it ain't that
you know it just because it it ain't no
catwalk down here just the other night
yeah you have to have you have to keep
your awareness all the time
because you don't know what element
you're dealing with this and that i'm
walking down
and talking to somebody and there's some
commotion going
on just right at the corner and i'm just
you know uh
laliga and the person said hey i'm hey
stop i'm trying to see what's going on
here
i said well they're just arguing i know
who's arguing
next is going to be a gunfire right
after that boom
they shot off some fight some uh a gun
and um i just it just woke me up you
have how you have to have your awareness
around here
i mean i don't know if somebody got i
don't think somebody got shot but i know
they were shot at
uh cops came immediately right after
that
so uh and that happens quite a bit
yeah i mean it's just people just the
mentality of people
down here are so different they're i was
telling the guy he was telling me how he
had to sleep with his big
knife and how he couldn't sleep in one
area one too long because somebody's
gonna get him
i said you know that's really [ __ ] up
you gotta think like that or live like
that
you know i don't live like that down
here you know i lived rather comfortably
until
you know lapd decided to take everything
of mine but
they they they did me my truck i didn't
care about
i could build another layer or whatever
the truck is what i used to to hustle
so they impounded that thing i don't
know if i'm gonna be able to get it back
but
i guess the moral of the thing is i
think i finally got i'm gonna i'm not
i'm not gonna leave
i'm gonna put myself in a program here
and then leave and go back clean
you know and i do rather well in
programs whatever i do i i do
i do you're like me yeah are you is that
how you are just i just i'm extremist i
guess it was not
i recognized that the first time we
spoke it's like when i do something
i either don't care and don't do
anything or i do exactly 100
that's me right there you know i go out
and i don't and i i
most people i mean i am a small framed
guy most people don't keep up with me
when i'm working
they can't hang you know i i i said okay
i'm going to do this today and i'm on
that
until it's done you know i mean
but um yeah i i you don't know
how many people i've talked to i
what are you doing here oh i came here
and i got stuck
so many people get stuck down here i
don't know
you know it's not
there's really nothing besides what do
you think the the core
reason for the addictions no i know
but on a deeper level it's not just the
drug addiction it's it's there's
something that's making them
well it's so convenient it's convenient
down here
yeah you don't have any responsibilities
none only what you want to put on
yourself
you mean some of them don't even choose
to have be responsible for a tent they
just sleep on the sidewalk
you mean and and they don't just i mean
trash anything i just it's just you know
i i can't live like that even down here
i don't live like that i mean
very clean very um but right now i'm
reduced to a one-man tent in
trash but it's time to go to a program
yeah
yeah i think i i think i hit the bottom
thanks to the lapd do you think
but i'm telling you they they they were
this i don't think anyone had a had a
lair like you did
no no that that's what the first thing
they said basically you can't be just
you can't be just framing [ __ ] up and
doing it i was gonna make it on wheels
so when they pulled this [ __ ] i just
roll it right off
but it was gonna the way i was gonna do
it i was gonna do it right was gonna
cost a lot of money
and uh that's now i'm not gonna do that
i'll just you know i had a uh
i wasn't on the concrete i was on a deck
i built a deck first
then put the walls and the awnings and
everything on there
so it was a lot of money
but i knew it was going to come down to
either i had to move it or tear it down
or something
but they didn't give me the opportunity
to tear down they just tore down
and i didn't get none of my stuff back
so i am i am going to go
file a claim and go after the city for
how they handle that because
you're not the property owner so yeah
you'll have a hard time there huh
you're not a property owner so you'll
have a hard time well no it's no i'm not
going after the property i'm going after
my belongings
they're supposed to bag and itemize
every belonging okay
that's there is guidelines you know well
even the homeless have rights
yeah i guess they do they do so um
and in most and they what they do is
what they do they keep half the stuff or
they
give it away or whatever whatever they
do with it um
most people down here don't pursue
anything they just
you know i mean they don't lose enough
to pursue or they just don't
care anyways and so they know this and
they don't they do whatever they want to
do
right i'm pursuing it i i'm pursuing it
because they did it wrong they didn't
give me they didn't give me no no really
no warning
you know they should allow me to do to
tear down myself
todd i think there might be better
fights to fight for you
you know anybody else i probably
wouldn't listen but you're probably
right
but i'm pursuing it anyway they did they
i don't think they did that right and
they're
supposedly but i'm going to research it
before i go make an
idiot myself what the guidelines are
what they have
you mean well i i admire your courage
for coming back and telling your
your story of debauchery no problem it
was a pleasure i just i i felt impelled
that
because i told you i was leaving it was
four or five months well i think i think
you're cut from a different cloth than
most of the people i interviewed down
here yeah
you're kind of like you know it's like
what are you doing down here yeah
you were just having a crazy weekend
last time i met you and now you're yeah
it's it's gone into this well like i
said the wife ain't changing and i
haven't been
been to get away from that relationship
for years
so she came up and showed me she
it was going to be the same [ __ ] over
and over again it ain't going to change
i just said well la's done one thing for
me it's helped me get away from my wife
i still love her if i go to san diego
i'll probably go back to her you know
what i mean
but she's she's she's to my well-being
she's just no good i mean just
even as much as i love her that's just
it's a
so i i discovered well la lisa did that
for me
so but i haven't found true love down
here yet
that's gonna be hard yeah that's gonna
be real hard yeah
because i i really am you know even
though
yeah you know you're gonna believe this
i've been with so many different
prostitutes here you're gonna believe
this line
and i know she ain't gonna believe it if
she sees this video
i haven't screwed none of them you
haven't wait i have not screwed any of
them
oh you haven't no so what do you do with
them
just a little companionship my intent is
to screw them
[Laughter]
but time i get done i just i can't do it
i've paid thousands and thousands of
dollars of these
these hoes and i can't do it that's
that's the thing i don't hold anything
everybody's trying to survive down here
a lot of them don't have means to
survive
so they just do everybody dirty i mean
and
you know which is not a good place to be
just doing everybody dirty because
you're gonna end up getting shot or
something it's gonna happen yeah i mean
i'm trying to do nobody turned you down
here um i'm not not do anybody dirty
period
but um that's just the way it is down
here
life on skid roll all right todd well i
wish you the best of luck
in your program and y'all thank you and
with life okay thank you
thank you hopefully we won't have to
have another interview
you